i will not anger under any circumstances
under any provocation
fine print i will not criticize people i
will not complain to people about their
behavior
i will not condem other people i will
not engage in escalating conflict
i know that you uh you uh
made this commitment with your kids that
you were never going to be angry
right and you put something on one of
their doors saying this is like a dad
angry free zone or something like that
yeah
which which i loved because it's really
you know it's
it's a it's a challenge to the self
right when you feel that impulse and it
made me think
about all of these buttons that we have
installed that are the result of the
experiences that we've had or the
traumas that we've survived
wherein when they get pushed we you know
logic goes out the window and
we just impulsively react and it's only
in the aftermath that we can
reassess or feel guilt or shame or try
to
repair whatever damage is done but the
trick is like
how do you uninstall those buttons or
you know kind of uh
um un-trigger them well first of all is
the virtue practice
which is i call the four c's
i start with i will not anger
under any circumstances under any
provocation
fine print i will not criticize people i
will not complain to people about their
behavior i will not condem other
people i will not engage in escalating
conflict now i fail
but if i fail to my standard i don't
have an excuse i just failed
now i set that every day i mean when i
wake up
i will not anger and i will not be
defensive
i will not criticize complain condemn or
get engaged in escalating conflict
someone's upset with me after a couple
of tries i'm not going to engage what i
call the bad jedi
justifying i have all these acronyms
okay that jedi i've never heard that oh
yeah the bad
i will not justify to an angry person
after i try to
explain my point of view because
oftentimes i'm sorry but
never oh my god someone says that i will
set out on my boon squad i will hunt
them down
i say to people if you're going to study
with me you never say i'm sorry but
an apology is an apology and by the way
that's a big thing for some people
they've actually never heard the gold
standard apology
okay so anyway so i will not justify
explain
defend deny try to give more information
to a hostile person
so those are my that's my virtue
practice under any conditions whatsoever
if i find myself upset i say
okay i've already committed i'm not
going to do it
now my emotions are not obeying me
so what i call the wall of virtue steps
between my emotions and my speech and
behavior i call this the wall of virtue
so i set up a wall of virtue that says
i can have anger i can feel anger
i will not speak it i will not act on it
okay so i say it hits the wall of virtue
bounces back into what i call a wisdom
mill so i got all kinds of cool names
for this stuff
okay so that's but that i set myself up
and people who i work with whom i work
they tell me about all the escalation
and i say okay
wall of virtue time i do this my i have
a wednesday night wisdom class
and it just began last week wall of
virtue
for the regulars it was a great review
for new pump comers it was the most
stunning thing they had ever heard
that when you get up in the morning you
set up a wall of virtue and there are no
exceptions and if you fail
you apologize and that's that's pretty
stoic it's a power yeah that's a
powerful practice
i i found that meditation and
mindfulness
go a long way towards creating that
buffer so
if you visualize it like you're you're
you're inside
of some kind of sphere as you navigate
the world and like what's going to
bounce off and what you're going to let
in
how how how porous is that membrane
mindfulness or or a strict meditation
practice just buys me
that little moment of self-reflection
before i act
and oftentimes that's the difference
between
doing something you're going to regret
or aligning your actions with your
values
exactly so that reflection practice is
what i call my wisdom practice
but the wisdom practice taught me to do
the virtue practice when i wake up
because what people say is i know i
shouldn't have done it my emotions got
the better of me
i say so your reflection creates a wall
of virtue
and this is actually mind training the
brain
because what happens is there's a
stimulus and a response
so i i train people what was the
stimulus
my child disobeyed me response anger i
said now i want you to try this
my child angers me wall of virtue
train and this is like martial arts
you know like the beginner in jiu jitsu
if someone gets on top of you what do
you why you would push them off
what does that mean arm lock
the instinct to push somebody off of you
is inviting an arm lock
so whatever you're going to do in jiu
jitsu do not push someone on top of you
because you're saying
please arm lock me well what do i do
instead
i say first you're not going to do that
right what do you do instead
i said okay you hide your elbows in your
hands and you move your hips
white belt the next week i keep
forgetting because you're a white belt
right so when you feel the instinct to
push your arms up
instead you hide your hands and arms and
turn on your hips
and it takes six months so it's called
an intervention
when i get the stimulus okay now not i
don't have somebody on top of me right
i have let's say the disobedience of a
child
i've trained myself that my response is
going to be wall of virtue
which is like hiding my arms and turning
on my hips yeah it takes training
so how do you train i say you wake up in
the morning and you train
i do the thing you train you say wall of
virtue
no anger no foresees no bad jedi train
train train
and one day your kid's going to say
something you're going to go well to
hurt you
um but good eye good jedi training
is is the path right i i often think
what would a jedi do
in this situation jedi never reacts yeah
never loses their [ __ ]
yeah and jedi's gonna have fun they can
joke and they're spontaneous but the
minute things go wrong the jedi says oh
oh we're in that space now okay
there's an adult in the room okay
i'm gonna hold down the moral center so
the kid does something say oh so you've
changed the game you're doing the
disobedience game
okay i have a response to that yeah but
i'm not
going to give myself a moral arm lock
right because pushing is like arm lock
me
right that's a white belt thing right so
you want to go up in the belt
when someone does something to anger you
wall of virtue kicks in well what you
resist persists
right in that way
because if you're if you're in that
context
you're allowing your child to do what
they're doing you're not pushing your
arm out
to use the jujitsu analogy
um you're kind of you know adjusting in
a counter-intuitive way
um but the pushing back is what then
amplifies
exactly so ideally if my child does
something um
look my kids are my youngest is now 24
but still it can happen and
typically if if she does and she'll
probably listen to this if she does
something that i don't like i'll
probably say
yes that's not working for me right now
so i'll talk to you later uh-huh
and she'll say the same thing with me
she said dad it's not working for me
and we disengage right and then we'll
talk about it later
right so the thing is you train yourself
when i feel
anger i go to the wall of virtue
and then i have a script waiting for me
which is it's not working for me right
now
can we talk later now that's training
that's what a good blue belt can do
right you don't do what you feel like
doing you you've
learned a next behavior and a purple
belt it's become
their habit they don't even have the
instinct
to make a wrong move because the the
game they've ingested the game yeah the
training has been ingrained yeah so you
know this
how often does uh jiu jitsu find its way
into your
rabbinical sermon like i would imagine
[Music]
you